- [Instructor] In this
video we're gonna talk about
different ways of structuring an economy.
In particular, who owns what
and how does an economy
decide what to produce
and who gets the output
of that production.
So on one side, you have what's
known as a command economy
and good examples of command economies
are the communist states,
especially during the 20th century,
The USSR, the Soviet Union
being the best example of that.
In a command economy,
the government controls
what's often known as
the factors of production
and sometimes, in an extreme case,
there might not even be private ownership.
So lets say that this right
over here is the government.
I'll do this with some type
of a building with pillars in it.
So this is the government.
And in a command economy,
the government will often own
the factories and the farms,
so the factors of production.
So let me draw a little factory here.
So with a little smoke stack...
And so the government
will tell this factory,
"This year, you have to
produce exactly 10,000 cars,"
"No more and no less."
and so that factory say,
"Okay, you're our boss,
you're the government."
"We will produce exactly 10,000 cars."
Similarly, the government might tell some,
let's say that this right
over here is a farm,
and this is my best drawing
of a field really fast,
and so it needs to say
"Hey, you need to produce",
I don't know, "10,000,000 apples,"
I don't even know
if that's a reasonable
amount of apples to produce
but you need to produce 10,000,000 apples.
And so the farmers who essentially
work for the government,
'cause the government would own that farm,
they would produce those apples.
And also in a command
economy, there's like
well who gets these cars
and who gets these apples?
Well, in an extreme command economy,
they will be directly
allocated by the government.
The government will say,
"Alright, you get a car, you
get a car, you get a car."
and it might not be based,
and in fact it will not likely be based
on any type who's willing
to pay for the car
or who could pay the most for the car.
Similarly, for the apples.
So they are all gonna be allocated.
So there will have to be
a lot of planning done
on the part of the government to say,
"Okay, how much should
we produce of one thing"
"versus another thing
and how do we decide"
"who gets the different things?".
Now the other side of the spectrum,
you have what's known as a market economy.
And most economies in the world,
especially the United
States, are much closer
to being a market economy
than being a command economy.
Rather than having the government owning
the factors of production,
deciding who produces what
and how much and who gets those things,
in a market economy, it's
all based on the factory
right over here, independent
of the government
for the most part unless
you're in certain fields
that might have strong
influence from the government,
let's say you're a military contractor.
But if you're not in one of those fields,
if you're fairly independent
of the government,
what they would say is,
"Well, what does the market need?"
they might say, "Hey look,
the market needs 5,000 cars"
"That look like this
but then it also needs"
"another 2,000 trucks
that look like that."
and how are they basing it?
Well, they might have looked in the past
or how well is this car selling,
how well is the truck selling.
They might look at competitors,
in fact in a market economy,
you'll often have more competition.
The command economies,
you might have one
really ginormous factory
that's owned by the government or a few
while here you might
have competing factories
where they're always
"Hey make a pretty good
car, we're gonna make one"
"that's just as good
and it comes in yellow."
So once again, you have
this notion of competition
for people to produce
things out in the market
and they're also making
their best judgment
of what does the market actually need.
Similarly, you could have
your farmers here and you say,
"Hey, you know what?"
"I've been growing a lot of apples"
"but that doesn't seem
to be in demand anymore"
"so I'm going to grow more,
I don't know, peaches"
"'cause it looks like the sale of peaches"
"are in fashion this year."
and similarly, who gets these
is not dictated by the government,
it's determined by the market.
And so let's say this is
me, let's say this is you,
let's say this is someone else.
If I might not be interested
in getting a truck
but I really need to get
a new car for my family
so I can drive them around
and take vacations and things,
and so let's say you wanna get a car too
but the market will dictate who gets it.
So for example, the factory
might set a price for this car,
they might say it is
10,000 dollars per car
and maybe I'm willing to
pay it, maybe I'm not.
Maybe I'm just like "Well I
really like that blue car"
"but I'm not willing
to pay 10,000 dollars"
"and this yellow car is
available for 9,000 dollars"
"so I'm going to get that."
and the prices themselves
won't necessarily be fixed.
If they're not selling
enough of these cars
at 10,000 dollars, they
might lower the price
to compete with the yellow
car at 9,000 dollars.
Similarly, if there's a ton of people
who are willing to pay
the price of this truck,
they might raise the price on the truck
or produce more of it.
In this severe competition,
if one firm doesn't do this
well on a regular basis,
they might go out of business.
So there's a strong motivation
to be able to meet the needs of the market
and then the prices adjust accordingly.
And so you might say,
"well what are the
positives and negatives"
"that people generally associate"
"with command economies
or market economies?".
Well, the motivation that's often given
for a command economy is
some notion of fairness
or some notion of equality
that when you have a market economy,
as a byproduct of this mechanism
where different people are competing,
some people are innovating more or less,
some people might be
working harder or less,
some people might just
get luckier or unluckier,
you naturally will have
some level of inequality.
And some of the original
ideas behind command economies
like communism where hey we
don't like this inequality,
we wanna see more fairness.
And so we wanna see everyone
get exactly the same car.
We wanna see everyone get exactly
the same number of apples.
We don't wanna see all
of these competing firms,
we want one really big, efficient factory
to just churn out these cars.
Now it turns out in reality,
that's a little bit utopian.
Even at the peak of some of
these communist economies,
there were people who had
better access to certain things.
People who might have carried
favor with the leadership,
had more power, who had better
apartments, better cars,
had more access to resources
and people who didn't.
In a market economy,
yes, there will be some inequality,
but the best thing going for it,
and the reason why most
economies in the world,
even ones that are nominally communist
like the Chinese economy,
have transitioned to a market economy
because a market economy
is also associated
with things like innovation
and strong incentives for people
to innovate or work or do things.
Think about the situation
in a command economy.
Let's say that you're a
manager at this factory here.
The government told you to
produce exactly 10,000 cars
and exactly the type of model,
maybe you have an idea
for how to make this car more efficient,
but no one is really
gonna reward you for that.
If you're not gonna be
able to get paid more
so that you can buy more things,
you might not be as
interested in doing it.
While in this situation,
you have extreme competition
where as soon as this
factory or this company
is outselling this one,
everyone here is gonna think
"Wow, we need to innovate."
"We need to really work harder"
"so that we can take more market share"
"from the other company."
Similarly, at the individual level,
different people might say
"Hey, I can only afford
the yellow car now"
"but gee, I really wish
I had the blue car"
"so maybe I'm gonna work
a little bit harder"
"or I'm gonna try to innovate"
"or I'm gonna try to start a business."
most of the world has
transitioned to something
much closer to a market
economy because overall,
even though you have this inequality,
it has made more
productivity, more innovation,
more goods and services
available to more people.
Now the reality is most
economies, as I mentioned,
they're close to a market economy,
but aren't a perfect market economy.
You still have the
government very involved
in certain industries.
In many economies,
the government might be
in control of healthcare.
The government in almost every country
has significant influence
in things like the military.
The government, in say the United States
which is considered a fairly capitalist,
a fairly strong market economy,
the government still does
offer social safety nets
when the inequality gets too extreme.
If someone isn't able to feed themselves,
they might get food stamps.
If someone isn't able to get
healthcare because of poverty,
they might get Medicaid.
And so there's actually a spectrum
between a command economy
and a market economy.
With most economies
actually falling in this
inbetween state which
is sometimes referred to
as a mixed economy.
For example, as I already mentioned,
the United States which is considered
a very capitalist country
with a market economy,
it still does have some public ownership.
The government still does
control certain aspects
of the economy, it still represents
a fairly large chunk of the economy.
And so a pure command economy government
would control everything,
pure market economy, you
would have very little
that's controlled by the government,
but the reality in most of the world,
things fall in this
mixed economy spectrum.